Joe DeRosa here from the taste buds
podcast folks I'm live and I'm coming at
you all over the place
uh I'm coming to Houston Texas this
month uh to do the come and take it
Festival I will be there doing my new
one hour show I Never Promised You a
Rose Garden check it out folks that's
being held the secret group in Houston
Texas uh also December I'll be a coastal
creative in St Petersburg doing the same
show two nights I'm also doing we'll see
you in hell live down there with Patty
Walsh come see us for that December 14th
New York City crane theater back again
doing I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
for all you find New York and folks also
in January the Vulcan in Austin Texas
and governors on Long Island and then a
ton more dates coming up in 2023 go to
Joe
torosainfo.com for tickets and show
times and come to Joey roses in New York
now open seven days a week at 11 30 a.m
every day booze sandwiches Good Times
joeyrosesnyc.com
all right guys the Impractical Jokers
are back on the road after three years
we just announced the tour is called the
drive drive drive tour tickets are
available
impracticaljokerslive.com all cities
across the country we start off in
Pittsburgh at the PPG Paints Arena we'll
be coming to the Prudential Center in
Newark the UBS arena in Long Island so
on and for so forth everything's on sale
right now and then uh that starts in
February before that my only two months
left to touring are November and
December November uh 11th Knoxville
November 12th two in Atlanta Georgia one
just sold out says you want to get
tickets get it to the second show 13th
November 13th in Alabama and then we got
November 18th in Louisville and November
19th in Evansville December will be
California and Florida check it all out
right now at savocanocomedy.com
everything's on sale merch is available
there for everything pick up some merch
I'll see you on the road taste buds they
come into the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two fools gonna fight but only
welcome to t-a-s-t-e buds here I am and
what better
guest host to have on a show about food
than a pig himself
Chris DeStefano yeah way to have me on
when I'm intermittent fasting oh my god
dude I haven't even been 17 and a half
hours dude I feel great you haven't
eaten in 17 years I'll tell you how long
I haven't eaten in I haven't eaten in
I'm on this zero fasting app which
should be a [ __ ] pod sponsor
um 17 hours and 30s the last time I ate
was 5 43 last night wait why are you
doing such big Windows because you're
supposed to do so you're supposed to do
16 hour fast like 16 hours of fasting
eight hours of eating yeah but if you
can push it to 18 6 like 18 hours of
fasting and six hours eating that's like
should hypothetically get you the best
results
and so I've just and then you exercise
on top of that you actually you're
supposed to exercise at the end of the
fast when you're in fat burning mode
basically you have to stop this app
broke it down where it kind of changed
my mindset he was like I don't know what
my Mac strength is when I have food in
my system he's a [ __ ] big Jack guy
he's like you know I might be able to
bench press 300 pounds when I have food
but I can only bench press 225 at the
end of the fast but that's what you
compare yourself to is getting better in
the fat burning mode not with food like
everybody's stronger and better when
they have food it's about what you can
do when you don't have food and the
thing is you can go the human body can
go 30 days without eating food so I can
go 16 8. dude I started when I started
this in in late August August 26 my
birthday was 2 45 now I'm 2 20. and all
every people just keep telling me I got
small shoulders I'm like I'm [ __ ]
Jack
dude you won't shut up about this
fasting what do you want to battle you
said can we battle fasting yeah
there were people waiting online after
Joe's uh show that like want to take
pictures with um you know gel but then
also because I would say they were
seeing me and then they got off the line
when I started talking when I said I
want my battle to be fasting they were
like I'm not a fan anymore dude uh yeah
I don't no I I hate your quilts my mom
made those gosh sorry this is deroza
dude she really did she knitted these
two no those are dope oh shut up don't
[ __ ] lie dude my mom from the Amish
Country she always used to bring home
every year we go to the Amish country
and she'd bring home aquilo it's a quilt
and a pillow and it was it's a quilt
that would like you would basically like
stuff it in it'd be a pillow and then
you could open up a latch and there was
a quilt in it oh God Jesus Christ what
happens when you have a divorced mom my
mom's country dude my mom she would go
to the Kitchen Kettle all the time yeah
I hated going there but then I when I
got older I started to really I haven't
been to Amish Country in a while but I
started to appreciate the Amish cooking
my parents endure they went Jersey now
they're near a flea market that has like
it has like this food court inside of it
yeah and two of the stations added are
Amish counters where it's Amish people
they make all the food yeah and did the
foods unreal they make like turkey legs
yeah ribs yeah all shoe fly pie we
should have battled shoot fly pie versus
apple pie
I don't know it's some Amish dish what's
in shoe fly pie uh pimp if you pull that
up yeah it's some Amish pie that my mom
used to get was pretty good
um
uh
I lost my train of thought completely
dude I'm telling you man oh wait fasting
when's the last time you ate
you might actually intermittent fast you
don't even realize no I'm doing I do it
I'm intermittent fasting but I do it way
less extreme than you do I do an eight
or a 10 hour eating window and then I
don't eat outside of that the last time
I ate was yesterday
at 7 15 p.m so that's not bad at all no
I'll I'll start today around 12 o'clock
well no when we finish this so by the
time we get out of here and done I won't
eat something till at the earliest 12 30
p.m today at the absolute earliest and
you are intermittent without even trying
yeah and I and I let myself go to if if
I can I'll stop at 8 30 and if at if at
9 30 or 10 I'm still hungry I'll eat
something else but I'll cut it off at 10
hours I won't go past 10 hours okay but
here's the thing I did celebrate last
night after my show and I did have
drinks so I had whiskeys so that breaks
the fat that breaks the fast yes but I
don't often do that uh yes you do no not
anymore that's what I'm saying I've been
on this this diet dude I drank once in a
in a in a full month I drank one time
for Halloween what did you do to to
replace it you replace it with
cigarettes no I don't smoke anymore no
I've been painting
I'm not kidding look it's over the
painting can you somebody give me his
paintings please no no no don't don't oh
no not not if not you don't want to
reveal the piece no uh let me see the
painting I'll show you once I finish
dude Leah let me see your [ __ ]
God
imagine that you just sit here and you
paint you're one of those guys that's
like you know you're you're you're you
fast but can't you see him in an art
gallery with the little thick glasses
yeah just oh man
just annoying yeah just talk to me about
like you know the the exposure and the
light on this paint that what inspires
him
all right
these are abstract paintings I'm not I I
you know it's just so what okay so what
so so explain what's this one I don't
know what do you mean you don't know you
gotta an artist always has to have like
tell me what does it mean there's
nothing behind any of it I sit down and
I just try to put stuff together that
seems to make sense to me sometimes it
works for me sometimes it doesn't and
the ones that I like I keep I liked this
one I really I like this one a lot
this one I really thought I mean this
one's just a penis me
yeah with teeth yo yeah it's your penis
I don't know it's just that like when I
was done I was like I don't know I like
the way this turned out would you ever
consider like selling them of course I
would I'm ready to sell anything you're
willing to sell this network
has been one of the founders in a month
you should do like a little art fair at
Joey Rose's trailer uh
I don't know about that but you know I
don't know come on I do enjoy it there's
my little station over there is that
where you paint too on that little table
you just kind of look out the window and
stand there I have the TV on I put music
on dude it's so relaxed you're like a
divorcee like a divorced older lady
you're literally like a divorced old
lady I know dude and this is what you do
uh you just sit here drink coffee paint
look you fast lose weight get depressed
it's [ __ ] great dude painting is so
relaxing
and I don't even know there's no
pressure on it whatsoever I'm not making
it for anybody uh I don't have to do
anything with it and I'm not by any way
in any way shape or form by trade and
artist uh in this sense so like I'm an
artist in other ways I think
uh and what tuna a sandwich already yeah
the perfect balance of mayo celery and
[ __ ] tuna fish you love the tuna
don't you love the tuna I like the fat
kid too the peanut butter and jelly with
chips yeah but I don't know there's just
no there's no Stakes here like you just
do like I said I do it and if I like the
way it turned out that's awesome and I
go this is really cool it makes you
happy I show it to people sometimes
sometimes they like it I have a couple
in there I'm really proud of on my on
the wall that I hung up that I did a
long time ago these are newer when's the
first time you painted when when did you
realize painting relaxes you I was
living in L.A
and uh I just
I thought it was uh you you know what it
was this is funny
this craze happened for a minute where
adults were buying coloring books okay
it was like this Colin Quinn made a
coloring book yeah well there was like a
trend though that was like going around
with older people and it was like it was
coloring and they were saying like
mentally it was relaxing to them it was
like a thing that was happening all
right and I I saw that and I had no
interest in doing it but I thought
I bet like painting is probably in the
same way relaxing covering to me
stresses me out because you it's like so
meticulous between the lines yeah like
and I just didn't and I also just wasn't
interested but I was like it seems like
it'd be like nice to just paint like to
just put and at the time I was starting
to buy some paintings for I had bought
that one for my bedroom when I lived in
L.A and I just I don't know I mean this
is terrifying this one that's for my
special
but it's awesome no it's it's awesome
but you know that doesn't freak you out
when you come in at night no but that
thing's gonna take 45 years old what do
I think if there's a monster in my
apartment dude I mean things like that
have energies oh sh oh my God bro I just
watched an episode of the new Unsolved
Mysteries the ghosts
for a guy for a guy that is red through
and through r e d red not r-e-a-d you're
certainly not that but for a guy that is
as a [ __ ] red voting gun toting
pickup driving [ __ ] hick like you are
you are such a queef it is unreal dude
dude like I don't understand like you
come out of the gate which side where
you'll be like ah crime's out of control
I gotta put a [ __ ] fence around my
house they got to build a wall at that
border oh my God that painting is bad
energy though
I'm not crazy consistency
um that that painting at night like if
you had to walk past that to go pee that
wouldn't freak you out no no obviously
it doesn't I used to have that I'm not
kidding dude I used to have that facing
my bed
and I liked it I liked it dude I like it
I like scary stuff at bedtime I like
scary like I go to sleep to horror audio
books a lot
so you'll watch an Unsolved Mysteries
you'll watch a like a crime
Investigation Discovery at night I'm
just not that interested in that stuff
show no but like no harm I'll watch I'll
go to sleep to a horror movie okay but
you look at all my movies they're all
horror movies I have a collection so you
don't you don't and you would do that
even though you like have like an app
you would do that in like a three-story
house like you wouldn't think oh the
monster is now in the kitchen it's gonna
get me are you
and I mean this respectfully stupid what
are you talking about dude dude do you
think a monster is in your head it's not
a real monster but doesn't it freak you
out like okay if you want okay how about
a real thing if you watch investigate
discovery about how a guy you know broke
into a house and and murdered everybody
and he's still on the loose you wouldn't
think that he's gonna be in your kitchen
when you go up to get a glass of water
not at all not at all that kind of stuff
doesn't I don't worry about that I hope
you get [ __ ] murdered I mean
I mean oh my God imagine taking the Rosa
hostage
and he saw he'd be the only one they
just let him go because they're like I
can't deal with his [ __ ] energy all
his needs
dude you would take people hostage you'd
be like you guys have bad energy yeah
then let them go the uh no I I no that
kind of stuff has never freaked me out
um sometimes if I'm walking in the
street
in New York at night and I see like
somebody looks a little shady I get a
little freaked like this guy could
attack me or something but that's the
only time ever that I'm ever worried
about a person potentially attacking me
I never worry about the serial killer
that doesn't freak me out it just
doesn't you could tell me there was a
serial killer actively on the loose in
New York and I wouldn't be freaked out
you would expect if he approaches me
I'll beat the [ __ ] out of him I don't
even know I it just wouldn't register
the odds
of it happening to you are so
astronomically small well what's a
serial killer to you more than two
bodies I mean well no she I actually
know what the definition of serial
killer my ex-girlfriend told me this
serial killer has to have a sexual
component to it that's the difference
between a serial killer and a mass
murderer a mass murderer could be a
Hitman he's murdered a massive people
that's all that is a serial killer there
has to be a sexual component which is
why
every serial documentary has a sexual
component all the ones they make the
movies and the TV shows about there's
always some sexual element because some
of the homeless people feel sexual I
don't know where there's a guy I'm
telling you there was a guy literally
and I've been living in New York my
whole life and I've never seen this once
there's a guy feet away from where we're
filming this podcast jerking off in
public at 10 A.M he was fully just jerk
slowly methodically jerking off I'm
getting used to it in Washington Square
Park a jazz band was playing and then a
homeless guy walked up with a metal rod
and kept threatening them and tried to
get him in the eye it was like that that
that would freak me out way more than
you know like like like oh there's like
crazy people on my street that could
have cost me at any given moment because
that's the neighborhood I mean that is
so much more active and potentially
threatening to me
uh or a concern to me than if you told
me oh my God there's a Strangler on the
loose in New York let's say you moved to
the Poconos 40 people you moved to the
Pokemon they confirm aliens are real are
you afraid in your house in the Poconos
no you're not afraid if you got abducted
by aliens that wouldn't scare you if
you're getting if I got abducted
beam and then you're up in the stars I
literally got abducted yeah I'd probably
be scared oh my god dude I could see Joe
complaining to the aliens the tractor
beam made me nauseous I just want to
look at his tattoos they're like what is
this what is this one's Ark
I mean I could never that's why I could
never make a TV show like because I saw
I remember saying this to one of my
managers she wanted me to pitch a show
and I was I we had a thing mapped out I
was like I'm not pitching it she goes
why I go because Larry David exists and
I relate to it so much and I can never
do it it's been done it's been done
better than anybody's gonna do it that's
the guy I feel like I am I want to be
him
there's nothing to do what what what
could you do after that how could I ever
make a show where I complain all the
time I gotta wait like 30 years for
people to forget about that show when
I'm old and then maybe I can do it you
have a different flavor of complaining
you can do it dude I feel
I saw this the other day and I was
conflicted I was on the subway and there
was a homeless guy there you know who
was acting crazy and like you know
really freaking people out right but
kind of not not CR but you could tell he
was like walking around shuffling around
and then there was two guys you know
like guys are kind of like us like just
regular guys I think we're going to uh
Rangers game and we're in Rangers gear
and one of the guys the guy didn't do
anything and one of the guys said I saw
this word for it he goes listen to the
guy goes before you try to do anything
he goes I'll throw you onto the tracks
just understand I will throw you onto
these train tracks before you do
anything to me and unprompted like he
the guy the homeless guy wasn't doing
anything to him he was like right just
and he goes I'll [ __ ] throw you on to
the tracks so just think about that if
you want to get stupid right now Jesus
and it was like palpable people were
like holy [ __ ] and then the guy the
homeless guy just walked up the stairs
and left and people were like thanking
like five years ago I'd be like oh that
was [ __ ] up on those two guys like
don't but now it was kind of we were all
kind of like hey thanks for just saying
that because like the air he was
freaking everybody out well it's it's
it's it's interesting and everybody
relaxed we're not going against homeless
people no or unhoused or whatever you're
supposed to say now the but here's
what's CR here's what's [ __ ] up about
homeless people in New York City
I was trying to explain this to my
parents because that's another issue we
had at Joey Rose's where people like
like home like homeless people coming in
and just like hanging and get them to
start making the same way I said to my
mom I go here's the thing you think
homeless means like the the lady with
the cart with the cans in it that's not
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
guys that got out of jail that usually
have a place to stay they just don't
have a residence on paper right that's
the majority in New York of when you say
homeless yeah you don't mean like the
guy minding his own business saying hey
buddy can I have a quarter that's not
what you're talking about yeah you're
talking about a guy that usually sleeps
on people's couches right and does too
much [ __ ] meth to get his own
apartment right and then sometimes ends
up sleeping outside that's the guy that
shows up and and that there's a problem
now dude and that that is becoming
that is becoming the majority of what
you see with homeless people and the
minority of homeless people now is the
guy that like they would have made the
TV movie of the week starring Lucille
Ball about or whatever you know what I
mean like it's it's a it's it's we're in
a heavy time right now TT Jerry the
other day TT Jerry said the homeless
people that live on her block freak her
out and I'm like you I've openly
admitted that you used to jerk off the
Son of Sam in prison right and you're so
excuse to openly have sexual encounters
with their convicted serial killer and
you're telling me you're freaked out
about the homeless that live on your
block and it's true I'm telling you dude
and it's and look and it's I feel for
people that don't have a res I'm not
even saying that everybody in that
position is somebody that in some way
some of them listen to this podcast made
a mistake I'm just saying it's just
where we're at like there are a lot of
people there now that don't have a
residence uh but
it's not the way you think it is it is
not like it is not like this guy lives
on the street no no they live usually in
somebody else's house and then end up
out there once in a while and we'll do
some wild [ __ ] yeah what I mean like
it's it's yeah it's it's uh
anyway folks let's talk about salmon
this is this is oh my God I like this
element of taste buds now where it gets
you know political kind of [ __ ] on the
homeless a little bit when we turn right
to Portuguese we went way dark on when I
did hey babe with you we went what's
your energy dude this this is you this
is why you you keep wondering why this
is why I've watched Chrissy chaos dude
you're on there screaming about the
Democrats you know you're talking about
the the class war in Ireland or whatever
the hell you were talking about
yeah it's like people dude by the way I
I did that and then pimp shown we get
death threats from the IRA now because I
didn't know what I was talking about
yeah Jesus Christ dude yeah I mean one
tour and I thought I was an expert don't
don't act like you don't get there's a
reason Fox News keeps asking you to come
on you're saying something on chaos that
drinking them reach out to DeStefano
yeah give us a nice take uh we're doing
the battle today as Shaman versus pork
chops uh
all right we'll just get into it we
usually do a chant before the battle
have you do you know the chance because
I don't think we did them last time we
were here
so we have two chants we we have no
matter what happens I love you which is
one we did because the battles would get
too salty sometimes okay and then like
it would kind of feel like it was bad
blood afterwards okay so we use it
probably was yeah we so we would start
out going no matter what happens I love
you so we knew no matter what happened
at the end of it we were friends
that one I don't want to do with you I
want to do the it's time to get salty
one that was when we started to do
because the no matter what happens I
love you chance started making the show
too soft okay so we had to put some
Venom back into it so we started doing
what channel where we go it's time to
get salty we say that in unison three
times okay and then as soon as we're
done chanting that you launch an insole
with the other guy and it just gets you
in the mood to fight okay so so what's
the chance I'm I'm we go it's time to
get salty it's time to get salty it's
telling us all the and then I launch an
insult to you and then we do it again
and you launch it inside of me and it
has to just be boom boom yeah you can
you can hit me first and it's like
stream of conscience no you hit me first
so I know like it's so and it's just
like whatever the insult is yeah all
right all right it's time to get salty
you can fast all you want your body will
always suck
I [ __ ] actually hated your stand-up
power
let's talk bomb this what's their
mission what's their mission statement
to make the most comfortable clothes
ever what do you think of that man about
the sweatsuit is this sweatsuit they got
all kinds of stuff they designed well
they got socks they got shirts
they got underwear
all right and these are the clothes that
you can't wait to put on every day I
love a comfy sock I love a comfy shirt
and I love comfy underwear I gotta tell
you there's nothing worse than work than
coarse underwear
everything they're making over at bombas
is soft and seamless tagless it's got a
cozy feel that's another thing I hate
cutting the tags out of my shirts it
drives me crazy man
anyway there's a pair of bomba socks for
everything you do let's talk about the
socks there's a pair of bomba socks for
everything you do they come in a ton of
options for instance comfy performance
Styles made with sweat wicking Yarns
I thought it said yams like the sweet
potatoes it's Yarns and that means your
feet stay cool while the rest of you
works up a sweat bombas no show socks
are designed for Comfort while being
specially engineered to never fall down
I love that I when a nose show socks
slips inside the shoe
and did you know this people
socks underwears t-shirts are the three
most requested clothing items at
homeless shelters that's why bombers
donates one for every item you buy so if
you're a bombers customer you're helping
to donate over 50 million items of
essential clothing all right so listen
go to bombis.com taste buds and use the
code taste buds for twenty percent off
your first purchase that's
b-o-m-b-a-s.com tastebuds and use code
taste buds at checkout bombus.com
tastebuds promo code taste buds folks
raycon raycon good to hear from raycon
again raycon's been a sponsor of the
past we're glad to have him back raycon
is making earbuds and they make a good
earbud they make a good pair of earbuds
I don't know if it's ear buds or earbud
if it's like saying Buffalo or geese or
Goose I don't know what the plural is
but the point is raycon has a great
product especially at the holiday season
when you're looking for a gift that
everybody needs or a nice stocking
stuffer all right that's not a candle
for God's sakes or a calendar my mom
buys me a calendar every year I want to
throw it across the room
she hasn't grasped that calendars are on
your phone now and it's a terrible
calendar too that she'll get me she'll
give me like cars like I'm 12.
she gets me calendar like like like I'm
12 or like I live on Staten Island like
Sal
[Laughter]
anyway raycon earbuds are a great
stocking stuffer they're wireless
earbuds as you may have guessed uh they
also have headphones and speakers that
offer premium sound uh useful features
and an almost custom comfortable fit uh
and up to 54 hours of battery life which
I really like the person you're gifting
them to is going to love it uh and
you're gonna love it too by the way
because these start at half the price of
the premium audio Brands I just like
what raycon's doing I I use these
earbuds they're they're very seamlessly
able to connect to your devices they're
very easy to use they sound great and
and and they're half the price without
dropping in quality that's a key thing
to mention here usually you see a more
affordable pair of earbuds and they
sound like crap raycon they sound great
anyway
go to
buyraacon.com tastebuds you're going to
use a promo code taste buds to get 20
percent off site-wide everything again
buy recon.com tastebuds use promo code
taste buds and that's for 20 off any
raycon product on the entire site and
they almost never do this this is a
really good deal or you can save even
more with 30 off when you get raycon's
exclusive holiday bundles again
use promo code taste buds go to buy
raycon.com tastebuds for 20 off your
raycon purchase rake by raycon.com taste
buds here we go all right it's time to
b-a-t-t-l-e buds salmon versus pork
chops Chris hates pork chops with a
passion dude wrong with him and I said
what do you want to defend against pork
chops I said I said take a healthy meat
like turkey he goes I hate turkey
disgusting he thinks turkey who think
listen I've heard of people being like
ah turkey's boring I don't care who
thinks turkey is disgusting I used to
eat turkey all the time until Where I
Live Now on Staten Island there's wild
turkeys everywhere everywhere and I
watch them walk around Lawns and eat
deer [ __ ] all [ __ ] day and they're
disgusting and once you see an animal
dude they open they went through the
garbage the other day and they opened up
my daughters my one-year-old daughter's
diapers and ate her [ __ ] out of the
diapers and just left them open and it
was the turkeys and he left them open do
you think they were gonna do close them
back up yeah have some decency and now I
have to eat you now because the pilgrims
said you tasted good thank you really
should turkeys eat chicken steak that
anytime you see a deer population so
what will you eat at Thanksgiving this
year honestly just the sides I'm gonna
eat like the mashed potatoes you know uh
uh uh would you eat chickens yeah I'll
eat chicken chicken I know chicken now
listen I I chickens eat [ __ ] like that
I'm aware that chickens are probably
kept an even more disgusting conditions
they say like in cages and they're all
[ __ ] on each other's heads and stuff
but I don't see it to actually see a
turkey in the wild and just look at its
fat [ __ ] neck it's disgusting dude uh
they say about uh they say that if you
go and see pigs and what they actually
do you won't want to eat it's like the
Samuel Jackson Pulp Fiction yeah these
are like pigs root and [ __ ] or whatever
yeah and like smart pigs or octopus
you'd never eat calamari again if you
saw how smart an octopus but that's a
people make that argument about pigs
because you could have a pig as a house
pet but at the same time they're
disgusting when they're with each other
yeah so so I think between the two you'd
probably be off the pig they would not
eat pig anymore uh who would have a pig
who would have a pig as a house pet you
never saw a little pot belly pig it's a
door what are people doing no dude just
get a dog or a cat no but I know but
popular they're adorable dude and they
don't make any noise
you're gonna have a [ __ ] pot belly
pig walking around your apartment I
would yeah I got one now for paintings I
got it now right here sit on the couch
I'm a fasting Pig
uh but here's the thing people say that
about pigs people also cue once actually
we did it on this podcast we did steak
versus chicken he showed me a video
of cows if you play music near cows the
cows will migrate to the music together
and stand and listen to it
and he showed me a video of it like they
do it like in Ireland in England like
they'll be like they'll do these videos
where like there's a musician at like
the base of a hill and it's like a
prairie or whatever where like there's
like cows and stuff and like he'll be at
the base of a hill and he'll start
playing music and cows start to come
over the hill and walk down the hill in
a herd and just stand there and listen
to the music dude it's the most
endearing I actually showed you that and
elephants do it and there's a whole and
they get shot in the head with an air
gun and we eat them as Burgers
immediately I think they get served in
your restaurant well I gotta tell you
dude with on the diet I've been on I
haven't been eating red meat and I
haven't been eating pork which you know
she's not even gonna eat your argument
I'll I'll argue it all day as a food I
mean I'll argue it all day but my point
is I haven't been eating red meat or
pork because you know they're very fatty
Meats whatever to eat and I and by the
way save your [ __ ] messages please I
don't want to hear it every time I talk
about this on a podcast people start
emailing me oh bro you're falling into
the cult of the doctor all you gotta do
is eat don't you listen to Rogan just
eat cheese all day and you'll go into
ketosis I don't want to hear it please
yeah I don't want it I've tried ketosis
it doesn't work for me uh this diet is
working for me anyway how much weight
have you lost that's not a shot at Rogan
by the way and that's just people people
uh I weighed myself this morning I'm 200
pounds dude I was 200 I was too
I think I was 214 or 215 somewhere in
there is at my heaviest how long ago was
that
a little over a month ago
okay that's and 215 was the heaviest you
ever were in your life
I think the heaviest ever was in my life
was like 217 or maybe maybe 220. and for
you it just carries bad right Carrie's
terrible oh just and look I still look
terrible
but no I I don't know I
just want to go uh and like you know two
I weighed in at 200 this morning that
could just be I'm catching myself at a
good time I try to weigh myself once a
week in the morning you know so but um
but consistently I've been in the low
twos right now that's good and you feel
good there well no I want to get down my
best weight I was ever at I got down to
180 pounds really I was like fluctuating
between 100 and 180 and 185 what were
you doing then that to get you down in
that way I I did the paleo diet which
I'm not doing now which is that that's
just like anything a caveman would have
eaten right yeah it's just it's
basically meat and vegetables and that
you you can have steak you just they
tell you to have grass-fed steak right
but I I just I was doing paleo and I was
doing uh I would run a mile three times
a week and then I would do like I would
lift dumbbells three times a week
God it's such a girl workout
to run a mile and then lift dumbbells
you don't even know how to talk gym talk
lift dumbbells what do you talk what do
you mean dude free weights I would run a
mile three times a week that was all I
did oh my God and you lost all that
weight was your body toned I didn't
drink either oh that's the biggest thing
I didn't drink and you didn't have bread
you didn't have much gone but would you
cheat on it without desserts and [ __ ] my
cheat no dude my cheat would be like I
would eat like
um
I would eat like tacos like and the
cheat would be because I was having like
the cheese and the shells how long did
you keep that up for the Paleo Diet
you know what's funny dude I was with
Giannis
in Florida when he was doing that gig in
Miami
I went down to write with him for a week
he was doing this thing where he was
hiring Comics to come down for a week at
a time to write with him on the show I
was there when he quit he went in the
other room and quit I came back and he
was like I just put my notice in and
then we didn't do any work I just sat
there look at this [ __ ] painting dude
it's your energy
I just sat there with him for a week in
this [ __ ] office we didn't do it he
just hung out in Miami but
um yeah dude we uh but I was there with
him and we went
we used to do this thing you me and Yani
used to go clothes shopping together
and he used to he thought it was funny
that I would talk I would call it the
drobe yeah I'd be like let's go get
stuff for the Drone yeah yeah and uh and
um we went clothes shopping when I was
there one night and we went like bat
[ __ ] dude he took me to this mall that
had all these great stores and we went
Hog Wild we bought all this hundreds of
dollars worth of stuff just I probably
spent I think I spent a grand in one
night with him just buying like which I
get you could buy two things and it
would be a thousand dollars if you go to
the right store right right but this was
these were like
seventy dollar shirts like that's how
much [ __ ] I bought right you know what I
mean like I just and I brought it all
home
and I called him and I go dude none of
this stuff fits me anymore and he was
like what are you talking about you just
bought it because my body is weird it
will turn
like every five pounds it will be a
different like shape really yeah so like
it's happened to me now this t-shirt the
shape is this they're all bad shapes uh
but this t-shirt fit me like a [ __ ]
glove when I was heavier
and like
it's it's it's now it's not that it's
loose now that's the problem it's a
little looser but it just doesn't let
the arms flare no it looks fine but it
doesn't like the pits the the armpit
holes these things like this was tight
like none of it it doesn't look right
and it was like do it and I called them
and I go I'm telling you dude like my
like I don't know what happened like I
lost some weight
and then all of a sudden dude it was
like overnight I remember everybody
started being like dude you look thin
right and I weighed I started weighing
myself and I was like holy [ __ ] man I
lost like 20 pounds and you didn't even
realize because at the time I was like
205 or something and I got down to like
I said 185 but it didn't feel radical
your body didn't feel radically
different nothing felt radically
different and then once I went down I
didn't want to lose it
like so I kept going right and and I got
Denver I got down to a size 32 waist
inside skinny jeans what do you know
like 34. it's not terrible sometimes 33.
all right but I got down to a size 32
waist and skinny jeans and I was down to
a [ __ ] medium
button shirt did you feel good about
yourself then you felt like we felt
amazing oh okay you didn't feel like oh
[ __ ] I felt amazing and then when I
started drinking again
I would like have five that's pimp
that's where the pictures of me falling
asleep at the parties came from
yeah I would like because I would have
like four or five drinks and I would
pass out because like my body wasn't
getting any sugar right so the Sugar
Rush would like hit me from booze and I
would just pass you you would get worse
hangovers too right yeah because your
body was like what are you doing with me
but I was so [ __ ] skinny I remember
Naper got you said to me I remember I
wore a I I was doing uh something with
Rockstar Games and I had a they gave me
a baseball tee and I remember when they
gave it to me I was like don't even give
me this dude like I I can't wear this I
look I look I'm a lump of [ __ ] they gave
it to me I never wore it and then like
when this happened I put the shirt on
and it fit all of a sudden and I
remember Nate bargatzi see me in the
shirt and he was like bro dude like you
can wear those kinds of shirts now you
you're doing something right man yeah I
was like
and and then like you know like anything
else like I was in I was in good shape
for a while I wasn't toned but I was
just thin
and then you just slowly slowly went
back because you start to do the math
and you go like
oh my God if I ate
4500 calories today I would gain a pound
right and you go so I'm not gonna do
that but [ __ ] it I'll go get McDonald's
right you know and then you start to
just slowly but surely it creeps back in
you start drinking too much because
you're drinking you're you're eating the
wrong dude that's why I like the fat
calories because it's not a diet it's
just if you stay in the time frame of
the fast hypothetically I mean yeah you
can't eat 5 000 calories but like if you
give your body enough time like 16 to 18
hours to like start it starts to eat
your fat cells right and you just start
to like so you still like because I like
I'll do like this like like the soft
fast window I'll do um like I said I'll
do the uh
um
uh 10 hour window and but I'll have like
not every day but like I'll have cake
yeah I have days on the I had a day on
the faster I went to a diner with my
buddy and I got a piece of cheesecake
and a piece of chocolate cake at the
same sitting yeah I just I didn't eat
all of it but I ate a lot of both
because I was like I'm just I was in the
mood for it I was craving it and I think
I do that every other day I mean dude I
had [ __ ] I had a crumb cake yesterday
I ate crumb cake every day crumb cake
you won't eat shout out beans and leaves
on Staten Island Great Pumpkin crumb
cake you won't eat pork chops you eat
cake every day every day [ __ ] animal
okay I know I can't figure out even with
fasting I want my cholesterol is so high
so your cholesterol still high uh well I
gotta check my blood pressure my blood
pressure just went down from the
medicine but it's still like like
genetically I'm just I've you know but I
think genetically I'm predisposed to
like cake yeah I love crumb cake I'm
doing all this because I had high
cholesterol and I have fatty liver which
is why I had to also yeah but anyway go
ahead with the uh salmon wait why do you
hate pork so much dude okay first of all
I think the reason why I don't like pork
chops is a stupid one I understand
because people like oh will you eat
bacon I don't like ham either the only
Pig product I like is bacon which I know
is like fine is everybody likes bacon I
fell off with bacon you don't like bacon
bacon and I like a BLT and I like it on
a cheeseburger other than that I don't
give a [ __ ] about it anymore
no I just uh it lost me somewhere I
don't know I know I've slipped I used to
always go bacon egg and cheese now I go
avocado egg and cheese oh dude I love a
sausage egg and cheese or a ham egg and
cheese it's like that's a different
battle yeah see I don't like sausage or
I don't like sausage sausage you hate
Italian sausage yeah I don't I rarely
eat it I don't know what it is I don't
like something about a pig and I think
what the pork chop is is because of my
cousin once when we were little kids she
was like oh you know if you leave a pork
chop out in the sun maggots come out of
it which is probably true for any meat
or maybe it is yes but I just always
associated with pork chops so wait so
where do the maggots come from by the
way does that mean the maggots are
always there no it's bacteria eventually
grows in the meat and then it becomes
you know and maggots like it becomes
maggots so technically then the bacteria
the the the embryo of the magnet is
always in the meat
I guess in theory but like meat breaks
down as it breaks food breaks down this
food breaks down bacteria forms and
grows well you know you turn into
maggots in a coffin no yeah right you
are maggots we're maggots yeah so so
what are you upset about that I [ __ ]
it's double cannibalism if you eat pork
it's the maggots and the pig I know dude
I just for me at pork chop there's
nothing about it I just don't to be fair
I don't I barely eat steak I barely eat
anything like like what on an entree but
your house a whole Carvel cake it's not
easy I like sweets I'm not an entree guy
dude it's you have the weirdest like
Achilles heel Foods
sweets makes sense I don't drink that
much either I know sweets makes sense to
me like I get that you know people have
a sweet tooth but the things you have a
sweet tooth for are so odd to me because
odd
yes it's weird that that's like a go
like that's like because usually people
go I have a sweet tooth I eat a whole
bag of cookies I can't you know what I
mean right or like I go out and I get a
chocolate cake and I can't help myself
or my My Buddy goes my buddy's like dude
it's the sheet cake at the grocery store
it's always something like that it's
Oreos it's a sheet cake it's chocolate
cake it's pies it's that kind of [ __ ]
you have a weird Sweet Tooth it's like
I've never heard somebody go I have a
sweet tooth I Can't Get Enough tiramisu
or you'll be like dude look at what I
just ordered and you'll show me you'll
text me your Carvel order and it's like
the caramel daddy Sunday or something
it's like it's weird Sunday Dasher yeah
it's weird
it's never it's never it's like I would
think it would be like hot fudge sundae
yeah that's a classic Banana Split
that's a class so I almost never get I
almost apple pie That's a classic dude I
never who's cooking somebody's cooking
in this dude I'm so hungry right now I'm
just [ __ ] General Kate's real food I
got something about that covered what's
Kate's real food Kate's real food so she
make it's she I don't know if it's a
lady or what I don't know but dude they
make
um they make this this product and it's
like they make like these lemon bars
okay they have like different flavors my
favorite one is the lemon bar
they make a lemon bar dude it tastes
like a [ __ ] lemon square but is it
healthy dude that's how good does that
smell that's pig is that pig yeah the
smell dude it's healthy Studio oats and
honey but dude I'm telling you you
there's six ingredients it you want me
to get one you want to try it should we
just eat one yeah let's just eat one
people get so mad when we eat on this
one they're gonna have to [ __ ] deal
with it
folks you got a busy busy holiday season
coming up right now and that's why I
want to talk to you about Factor all
right it's time to plan ahead for these
holidays you're going to be running
around like crazy you're going to be
running out of work running to the store
I forgot to get this the family's coming
I forgot a present for so and so oh my
gosh I forgot them this kid's
grandparent or Godparent or whatever it
is it's a busy time people you got
decorating to do you don't need to worry
about hitting the supermarket and then
trying to figure out how to buy the meal
that's going to fit into your your
health thing that you're doing or
whatever your diet stipulations are
factor
factor is sending you meals people they
got 34 meals per week that they can send
you including Gourmet plus keto calorie
smart vegan veggie and 36 plus weekly
add-ons you'll have plenty of nutritious
flavorful options to choose from I Love
a pre-made meal when you can get one
factor is like if Lunchables were good
you know what I mean
yes if your grandmother made Lunchables
and was also diet conscious
as few grandmothers were when we were
kids
nobody
you know uh I mean it's just a great
thing my holidays are jam-packed luckily
factors fresh never frozen meals I like
that that they are they're never it's
amazing I love meal kits and there's
different meal kits out there and a lot
of the services are really really great
we've talked about some of them in the
show but I like factors send you a thing
it's ready to go it's pre-made and it's
not frozen and it's cheaper than dining
out people everybody needs to save money
right now especially when you got to
spend on the holidays put the money you
save towards your holiday fun and your
personal time I call it you time I don't
know what you call it but I call it you
time no prep meal no prep No Mess meals
saving you so much time so much planning
so much cleanup and so much money listen
head to go dot factor
75.com tastebud60 and use promo code
tastebuds60 you're gonna get sixty
percent off your first box that's code
taste buds six zero at go dot
factor75.com
tastebuds six zero to get sixty percent
off your first box
there it is
let's see this better tastes like a
goddamn oh lemon coconut nice
dude so so Kate they're not a sponsor by
the way I'm just I'm sharing this with
you here are the here are the
ingredients coconut honey almond butter
gluten-free oats brown rice crisps
lemon extract ground ginger sea salt
it tastes like a lemon square doesn't it
no
it doesn't have protein
I just read the ingredients [ __ ] hog
you could wait to chew it
three grams
um
yeah
by the way
I know I'm sorry I dude as soon as I
took it out of the wrapper I dropped it
Tim get up close up of this please
oh my God good
um
sorry
you're an animal I know
I'm
I like salmon
because
it's
got it's got a lot of protein for a fish
it's got a lot of protein you could put
it on sandwiches
you can eat it with mustard you can eat
a cold you can eat it hot you can eat it
on a bagel they swim uh the wrong way
they're swimming they're going against
the tide which is what I like to think
I'm doing in my life dude first of all I
think cold salmon is not preferable
first of all
there's something weird about there's
certain fish when it's cold I'm not that
into it like I Love Sushi don't get me
wrong but like
salmon trout
there's something about certain fish
that I like when they're hot when
they're cold it freaks me out a little
bit I can't put my finger on what that
is how do you eat cold fish and not get
sick
what do you mean like sushi right
it's not cooked but then like if I'm
cooking salmon you know Jazz will be all
over me like make sure that's all the
way cooked through but I'm like but we
eat cold salmon and we don't get sick
from that do they do anything to the
sound like how do we just how do we just
trust there's sushi grade fish what does
that mean
well why can't you eat what you mean raw
are you saying rods that are you cold
instead of raw sushi raw fish oh my god
dude you could be the dumbest man I've
ever met yes it's raw fish so honey did
you not know that yeah but how do you
get sick from it you don't get sick from
it
they're sushi grade fish there's certain
meats that you can eat either rare or
raw or you can eat beef certain types of
beef raw that's what that's what a steak
tartare is
I just he's right it says here they're
just the way the the fish is caught and
treated through transportation is
the reason because bacteria level is low
but you could still get wildly sick from
sushi
uh of course you get wildly sick from
anything if it's not K if it's not
treated properly or cared for the pro
the right way right you know if Sushi
goes bad and you eat tainted Sushi yeah
you're gonna get sick right but that
that's you if you eat tainted beef you'd
get sick yeah but my thing is it's like
like with salmon I just look at them
like I granted I don't love cold salmon
I like hot salmon but it's also the only
thing I can cook you know what I do you
know when I make my salmon first of all
I put it in an air fryer and I do a
marinade
I do a little bit of honey mustard in
the bowl honey mustard uh uh olive oil
salt pepper and a little adobo and I put
the salmon in I let it marinate in there
for like an hour and I cook it and and
the kids like it that sounds good yeah I
mean look Salmon's fine I have leftover
salmon in the fridge right now from
where I made it yeah
I'll eat the farm raised if I have to no
they're not orange they inject them to
make them orange the the salmon uh uh
that we eat is not naturally orange they
inject the food dye into them well wait
what color is it then when you get
salmon sushi it's it's like a reddish
color no I I think real salmon is an
orange like actual salmon themselves
aren't orange all right so here's the
thing though
without the feed in farm-raised salmon
yeah okay the um here's the thing though
it's it's salmon is good I like salmon I
eat salmon it's a great fish for you
it's very healthy as you said and it is
a very versatile fish I agree with that
too even if I don't like some of the
ways it's used but
I will tell you if there has ever been a
food on planet Earth
that you get zero excitement for
salmon what
you know nobody nobody is excited about
salmon in the Run nobody sits down in a
restaurant and goes ooh they have salmon
everybody's got salmon it's common you
go to a steakhouse that's got a raw bar
and a Seafood menu and everything you're
not going oh my God I I've got to have
the salmon over the lobster or even the
tuna or whatever or the king crab or
whatever it is salmon is the least
excitable fish that has ever I disagree
too I think it's up there with it's only
to be out boringed by like cod yeah I
was gonna say Cod is the worst dude
McDonald's serves Cod that's how cheap
it is yeah okay we're good sir no
seriously it's the one Cod I think
salmon is dude what do you think
Salmon's more exciting than halibut
I I see halibut way less on menus than I
see salmon but that doesn't mean it's
not exciting Alaskan salmon is just it's
pointers is you don't get excited about
it's a com it's like getting excited
about the roasted chicken you just don't
it might be delicious it might be a look
these are functional foods the salmon
is a food just like roast chicken I get
it for one reason I'm like this will
taste good
it will serve the purpose I will be full
cause it's got some fat to it and I
won't feel guilty about it afterwards
though that that's why I eat salmon
that's why I eat chicken I enjoy it I've
I my my taste for it has grown greater
and greater as I get older and I
continue to eat these things in place of
other meats but there's never a moment
in time where I go oh my God I can't
wait to go to that restaurant to get the
salmon
it's just not a thing dude there's a
restaurant on Staten Island called named
called Don Cheech they have the best
salmon you've ever had in your life dude
go get the salmon they crusted
pistachios or something no that's good
yeah the stand has an awesome salmon
where they do like an almond some kind
of almond crust on it or whatever but
I'll tell you this
they when they when and I get it all the
time and I love it but they'll they'll
do different fish for specials like
scallops or something when they tell me
that I get excited because I'm like oh
oh how do you do the scallops salmon
I don't know man that's why you're
single you get excited by scallops yeah
I go to a place they go they go in fact
the stand does this like what are the
special thing we got a we got a pork
chop that we do with shishito peppers
dude dude dude when you get a pork chop
cooked the right way with the perfect
brown sear and the moist it's juicy
oh my God and the fat on the end is
crusted and marbleized just the right
way or caramelized just the right way
it's just oh my god dude it's it's it's
it's it's it's otherworldly
put it on a sandwich it's it's a food
for Kings like if like you watch an old
thing about like Henry the eighth or
whatever or some movie about a king and
he's got a chop in front of him and
you're like that's a king yeah he died
of gout
you know what I mean you never ever see
a king in all one of those old you know
you don't watch Game of Thrones and
they're sitting there eating salmon it
depends if they were a seafaring people
a great comment from a fan here uh pork
chops are bland and only good with
applesauce that's I like that that means
they're not being cooked I agree with
him and salmon reminds me of derosa's
sister's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well that's the winner as far as I'm
concerned that's hilarious right yeah I
I listen here's the thing is for me pork
chops if you can't put it on a sandwich
I'm just not interested you can put up
what are you talking about I'm gonna
Chuck sandwich is a thing it has a bone
in it
on on the a bone-in pork chop does a
boat there's a boat you get pork chops
with no bone
Chris I swear to God sometimes I think
you've never left the house like I don't
understand have you ever gone to a
supermarket and bought groceries yeah
rarely oh my God what does Jazz I'm
Gonna Save Jazz from you I'm gonna give
her the life she deserves with a man
that appreciates what she's doing yeah
how like you like like yeah you go to
the grocery store yeah there's all kinds
of pork chops where you never single and
like cooked for you I'm not I'm not
being a dick I'm really asking no when I
the times in my life when I was single I
just ordered out every meal
all the time I know what I would do is
do it I swear to God there was this Deli
that I used to when I used to live in
loyal too it's called the Pumpernickel
Deli I would place an order at like 9
A.M and I would get like you know bacon
egg and cheese crumb cakes three coffees
and a chicken cutlet sandwich and I
would just have that throughout the day
I would just have like one order dude
you were a load yeah dude I can't wait
to get out here because I'm gonna go to
Parisi Bakery and get the dentist which
is a chicken cutlet proscute fresh I
thought you gonna go to my place you get
the tuna you shed no it's out of the way
you're such an [ __ ] no I'm fine I'll
get the no no no it's fine I'm not gonna
wait A lot of people are saying that uh
Chris actually ate a pork chop on hey
babe uh you were disgusted disgusted by
this the one time and and the person who
prepared it is an amazing cook and
prepared a lovely pork chop but I just
couldn't eat it I could I I ate it but I
didn't what because I kept thinking
about the maggots
I mean that's a psychological hang up
I hear you
there are certain
sorry you're choking on Kate's bar I
know choking on Kate uh there are
certain foods that I'll get a thing in
my head
like sometimes like a waiter will look a
certain way or a waitress will look a
certain way and they'll serve me
something and I'll get like an idea of
them with their like finger in it or
something and it skeeves you and it
schemes me big time and I can't get it
out of my head yeah mayonnaisey things
will do that to me sometimes skew yeah
like I I used to love sloppy joes and
like chop me and stuff like that and
then one time a waitress it brought me
to like you know sloppy Jones had like
all those moles all over her neck and I
just thought they were pieced our moles
were in my sloppy Joe and I could never
eat it again
that sounds good to me now a lot of
people are just chiming in that pork
chops are are like drywall they're
saying yeah they are they're dry they're
dry if it's not cooked properly you
gotta it's hard it's like saying it's
like saying steak sucks because it's
well done it's like no that's a poorly
cooked steak but it is a food that pairs
with the lube the applesauce is always
with the pork chop yeah that's that's
that's that's common but that's no it's
not that's not true a properly made pork
chop is very juicy oh God damn it I'm
gonna lose this [ __ ] battle come in
as soon as I come in I just win I didn't
prepare
this painting
so so pimp
already I think Salmon's gonna win this
thing
I don't know people would smell a salmon
versus the dryness of pork chops seems
to be it I'd rather smell yeah the last
thing I want is a dry meat let me shout
out everybody wrote pork chops to the
mush that's between your grandmother's
cellulite let me Shout Out who who are
we retweeting who's the winner with the
shaman quote uh uh the sister's vagina
thing oh geez I don't know I lost him in
the shuffle here what would you tweet
you all right but I just want to give
him a shout out if we can ah let me find
him all right we'll put his name up yeah
uh anyway follow that person it's called
fat mommy fat mommy yeah great uh do you
have any closing statements about pork
chops or uh my closing statements uh
about uh pork chops and salmon are that
um I think uh um I literally if I was if
I was being put to death in the electric
chair and they were like your last meal
all we can have is a pork chop I
wouldn't I would say no would you pick
salmon as your last meal one thousand
yeah
I want salmon in my coffin over a pork
chop you would pick salmon as your last
meal if you had the it could pick
anything you wanted not even [ __ ]
close dude I tell you this I'd rather
eat a bat from China than a pork chop no
but I'm I'm not saying that I'm saying
you could pick whatever you wanted for
your last meal you're telling me salmon
would be a contender for that one my
last meal no okay if we're being honest
my last meal there's really three
choices dead serious Pizza
fettuccine alfredo with grilled chicken
or cinnamon salmon with with the side of
mashed potatoes
fettuccine alfredo it's a grilled
chicken yeah oh my God and grated cheese
you are this podcast called are you
garbage
dude and a Tiramisu oh I like our all
right garlic bread what would be your
last meal how come you guys don't have
garlic bread at the sandwich shop put
some of these [ __ ] sandwiches on
garlic bread because we I don't know
because we get a garlic spread why I
don't know dude have like a [ __ ] uh
aioli no we don't we we do cold
sandwiches that's the whole thing I
think you guys should do I think guys if
you had a salmon sandwich it'd be better
uh uh never never uh uh do a salmon
special for me one week my last meal
would be
um
argue arguably uh surf and turf
never ordered that once in my life for
surface like lobster like you know what
forget the turf part I would go like
three three or four play on Lobster like
just again ordered a lobster I hate it I
love it I I don't want to do work to eat
my food I would do that you wear the bib
and eat it I wouldn't no I'm gonna die I
would love for you to be put to death
with the bib on you yeah
I do that honestly Taco kit I love Taco
kit what is that like taco kit meaning
like you make I love like the old El
Paso I love it so you want to construct
your own taco before
you eat the food I love it KFC would be
a contender like a huge KFC I have the
nerve to even comment that you're a
piece of [ __ ] KFC as as you're exiting
meal these are uh fried chicken is my
favorite my favorite foods are fried
chicken steak and lobster and taco kit
it's three things that I never even
think about eating or or ordering on a
menu ever I've never once in my life you
can't get two of them on menus I never I
I I'm being honest with you Joe I think
the land I don't think I've had fried
chicken like I've had bites of my
daughter's chicken fingers but if we're
not counting that like a fried chicken I
haven't had that in five years I have to
fight getting fried chicken I would say
on a daily basis yeah they open a fried
chicken place up the street and I'm like
I I have to like I have to like put my
head down like like a degenerate walk of
my prostitutes
uh no I haven't gotten anything in there
they have grilled chicken too which I'll
get uh you know or broiled whatever you
know like rotisserie I mean I'll get
that but like
I'm just trying to not eat you know high
cholesterol foods right now so Fried
Chicken's off the off the whatever but
cholesterol is in Kate's bar
I don't think you're right yeah you're
fine anyway folks all right let's go to
the poll whoever wins has to say the
other guy still love you okay you say I
love you too and that's it all right and
last place with 43 is salmon good God
thank you pork chop one 56 dude the
voting in this country's been off the
last few weeks
pork chop wins thank you taste buddies
and Tasties I needed a damn win I
appreciate it I still love you babe [ __ ]
all right thanks taste buds they coming
to the mic talking about the food they
hate talking about the food they like
two Fool's gonna fight but only one